today i want to talk about cyberpunk's
biggest mystery mr bluewise and his
organization
possibly named alpha centauri i want to
compile this information we have on him
so we can get a better understanding of
him and figure out what he's up to this
video is of course made before any dlc
and i truly believe one of the dlc for
this game will revolve around him or at
least his organization
if there happens to be any more info on
him in the future from a dlc or anything
else released i'll be sure to make
another video about him in the future as
always there will be a spoiler warning
for the rest of the video i'll be
lightly talking about a couple side
missions couple
endings couple main missions so like
usually we'll go beat the game and when
you're satisfied come back and watch
this but with that
let's get started first let's go over mr
blue eyes as a character and reference
his many appearances in game we'll go
more in depth with these in a little bit
but for now let's summarize to get
everyone caught up to speed
mr blue eyes looks like your typical
white male living in night city he
clearly has some money saved up judging
from his attire and the fact that he
sends v on an expedition to space but
his most notable feature is his blue
eyes blue eyes aren't uncommon in this
game this is usually when the player
transfers money
to another person but his stay on
constantly he also makes a physical
appearance in the paralysis questline
and in the ending path of glory but is
also hinted at during the sandra dorset
mission gary the prophet's mission and
related to a couple interesting theories
we already covered the parallelist quest
line extensively in the past videos if
you want to watch that i'll leave a link
to one in the top right or at the end of
this video but throughout the mission we
discover the paralysis couple has been
under the influence of a secret
organization making them forget past
memories and having new ones implanted
in them this is reinforced by our
discovery of a secret security team that
is inside the couple's penthouse spying
on them and reporting their behavior
when we discover the team and follow the
van there is an invisible av
that is located at the top and is seen
taking off and flying away but looking
at the van we say that they are
controlling people and possibly using
them for their own personal gain during
the end of that mission like we
discussed in a separate video we meet
with jeff to discuss what we found in
regards to the break-in on a balcony
nearby
is mr blue eyes just watching us it's
also heavily assumed he calls us before
we meet with jeff which is what you see
on screen from this quest we can
determine that mr blue eyes is either
the head of or a member of an
organization that uses people as
possible vessels
johnny also mentions the possibility of
rogue ai coming into the real world from
the net
an ai can't simply appear from the net
into the real world just by leaving the
net they need to use people as a host or
vessel to occupy their body and
roam free in sandra dorset's mission she
has us recover a data bank for her she
demands we don't look into it but if we
do we see a decrypted shard called
operation carpe knocked
carbonoctum by the way means c's the
knight in latin this shard refers to
tests in a.i
if we take the other info into account
it seems that these test subjects had no
idea that the ai was in their head and
that they were being used as a vessel
even mentioning that it managed to pass
through several security systems
undetected
it also seems that an hk13 strangled
someone over coffee then jumped out of
the building window
was this possibly linked to the suicide
scene we may see throughout the game
who knows they end it by saying that
they plan on installing the ai onto the
devices of their actual target from this
we get confirmation that ai
are being put into people so they can
use their body as a host and roam free
around the city
we can question sandra on this discovery
and she isn't too happy we know the info
of this but we can play along and tell
her we're cool with it
she talks about using daemons to hack
nightcorp one of the five largest
companies in night city and says that we
are correct when we talk about
conditioning workers minds meaning this
is exactly what this organization is
doing this of course relates to the info
we find in the peralas missions and her
room is three entries numbered 36 37 and
38. to summarize entry 36 talks about
sandra's attempt to get past the
nightcorp firewall she then finds some
files that talk about human dna and
flights to the moon for entry 38 he
talks about being followed by shady
people which may relate to the intro
when we first find her
gary the prophet seems like a guy who
speaks a lot of nonsense but he makes a
lot of key descriptions about these
people known as alpha centauri saying
that these people from alpha centauri
use synthetic skin and that they come
from space and spine the people of earth
gary talks about how he has a
co-processor in his head which allows
him to listen on to their communication
thanks to a faulty implant during the
peralas mission we notice a satellite
and receiver that is owned by militech
this organization uses this tech to
avoid interception which is why not many
have discovered who they are
minus of course gary this implant and
radio wave stuff that gary claims he has
sounds total [ __ ] until he tells us
of a delivery going on at a specific
location and by going there we can see
that he was telling the truth a group of
maelstrom goons and two unknown people
meet up make a deal then leave
meaning that gary isn't lying and we can
trust his word the weird question is is
that maelstrom is involved
this could just be nothing and they just
happen to have the chip or that at least
some of the gangs in night city work
with this organization as not only do
they appear in this quest relating to
this organization but they're also
protecting the van during the parallels
quest line when we spy on the meet up we
hear them talking weirdly like they're
quoting something and using it as some
sort of code
we intercept their meeting and steal the
chip but when we read the chip it seems
like more codes and riddles but by
reading the first letter of each word we
give project oracle command
execute plans we don't have any info on
what this project oracle is but assuming
it's related to operation carpe knock
them from before
it could be just another test run or the
actual plan of inputting the ai on the
devices of their target
or maybe they already have put them on
the devices of the target and they're
just waiting for the go-ahead to have
the ai actually take control
if that's the last option who knows how
long we have until jeff becomes the next
victim and is taken over himself just
like johnny takes control of us at
certain points in the game these ai
would control other people and it would
seem like nothing ever went wrong when
we return to tell gary the news we find
that gary is gone and was apparently
taken by blue-eyed people dressed in
suits according to his disciple
seems like gary knew too much and the
organization found out and dealt with
him accordingly the only other time we
hear about him is in the ending of the
path of glory
v becomes the legend of night city and
is sent on a mission by mr bluewise to
attack the crystal palace we discover in
the ending that we are on an arasaka
ship during this ending he talks about
sending some men together some tech
during the chaos at arasaka tower that
we of course caused and he seemed to
have stolen an entire spaceship
we also find out from the mission that
we aren't sent to attack the palace but
to steal customer data instead with
all the info we previously discussed it
might mean that they're going to be
finding more test subjects or more
vessels or maybe even something more
sinister thanks to this
it seems weird that mr bluewise only
officially contacts us when we cause
harm to arasaka so it's possible that he
could also be working for their
competitor militech which has always
been in competition with arasaka and
it's possible they want some lead in an
ongoing space race
which is why mr bluewise and his crew
steal the spaceship and task us with
stealing the data from the palace this
is further proved by info in regards to
the palace which is owned by esa or the
european space agency which according to
the wiki has had some trouble keeping
the lead in a space race thanks to the
japanese which of course as we know
arasaka is a mostly japanese company
on top of that like we stated before
during the paralysis quest line that
satellite and receiver is owned by
militech
so i don't really think it's a
coincidence that mr blue eyes here works
for militech so to recap
everything we just talked about while
it's not obviously confirmed there seems
to be an
insane amount of proof that mr blue eyes
is either the head of or a member of an
organization that uses the people of
night city as vessels for rogue ai
so they can escape the net and possibly
be used by militech to win the corporate
battle against arasaka
with this information though comes three
theories a rogue ai is the real reason v
is dying in six months
mr blue eyes is actually morgan
blackhand and a theory called the ring
of death origin gucci ring theory
for the first one this is because of the
intro when we jack into sandra and save
her we feel a little weird the morning
after and we have vic repair us a little
bit there is a theory going around that
sandra was originally a vessel for an ai
but because we jacked into her we ended
up taking those files or viruses
off her and becoming the new vessel now
obviously that doesn't mean johnny is
the rogue ai this means a third person
is laying in our head
dorman the only issue is the ending of
the game and alt cunningham
alt during the ending and even when we
first meet her should have detected the
ai within us and told us about it
this doesn't really help the theory and
if anything busts the theory completely
wide open
unless alt actually knows that the ai is
in our head but purposely withheld this
information from us
on purpose but from the ending all talks
about how no matter how much we try
we're still going to die in the end
anyway
nowhere in this speech at first does she
mention an ai at all what she says is
that the dna reconfiguration due to the
chip has progressed too far but she says
it's the chip's fault not another ai but
it's once again possible that alt either
didn't notice the ai in our head
mistaking it for the chip
or that she didn't bring this up on
purpose for some other reason our second
theory is the smallest of the three but
a very interesting one at that
some claim that morgan blackhand is
actually mr blue eyes it's reported that
he was at the heist of arasaka tower
back in 2023 with johnny except we never
see him it's possible that he was there
but in the game he was just never showed
after the attack he split off and went
under the radar for some time this is
all we know about him for now but
according to the game's files mr
bluewise's hair is labeled as morgan
blackhand
no clue why this is the case maybe his
hair happens to be the same as his
in-game
or this is a hint of morgan being mr
blue eyes i believe this guy we know is
mr blue eyes is actually a proxy for
morgan as we see with hanukkah during
the ending of the game she sends a proxy
with lit up eyes to speak with us it's
not actually her she's just speaking
through another person
it's possible that's why his eyes are
always lit up this is some random guy
who morgan or someone else is
controlling
what makes this theory even more
interesting is that morgan blackhand was
and maybe still is funded by militech
and as we talked about before
militech is plotting against arasaka in
regards to space technology so that
could be the connection this theory
needs but like i said it's one of the
smallest of the three and has tons of
holes in it but it's an interesting one
nonetheless
our last theory is just as intriguing on
certain npcs in the game is a ring they
all wear
specifically big joe from the street kid
path arthur jenkins and the corporal
life path as well as saburo arasaka jeff
perales gary the prophet hiromi sato mr
blue eyes and anders hellman many
believe this is a link to the
organization
the theory does have a couple holes in
it as it may just be an expensive ring
and that also a bunch of random npcs on
the street have them too but
if we play along with the theory these
people could either be marked as vessels
for ai or what i believe more
they're a part of the organization but
use the ring as a sort of code to let
other members know that they're a part
of the same group
lots of people have pointed out specific
symbols and different colors on the
rings which may mean something with the
organization perales has the same exact
design
as mr blue eyes except mr blue eyes has
a gold color as opposed to peralas as
silver
gary and hellman also have a similar
design of a devil or skeleton and
jenkins has a star other people have
pointed out some dialogue from other
characters and their actions throughout
the game as well for example the
mentioning of a queen lilith multiple
times by maelstrom and gary who
apparently is a rogue ai
we also have sandra who dug into more
info and helped with an experiment with
controlling people's minds so we
discover from her entries
hellman a man who worked on the biochip
and making the ability for people to
inhabit other bodies a reality which we
find successful from the arasaka ending
but just because a dead person can do it
doesn't mean an ai can't so in a way
he's helping them
then we have mr blue eyes who calls us
during the paralysis quest saying he
knows who we are
what we are in demind our own business
nightcorp somehow a top five
megacorporation yet nobody knows
anything about them and the many more
people involved
i believe this theory will be expanded
on it more if the dlc for this game is
related to this at all
if that's the case i'll cover all the
lore dating back to this theory in the
future assuming cd projekt
red goes through with this being part of
the dlc but regardless this is what i
believe to be the most plausible
explanation to who mr bluewise is and
what his organization is doing let me
know what you think of all this down
below i couldn't find the original
creator of this theory but i will give
credit to an ad comp psi
on reddit who compiled a really well put
together list of characters related to
this organization in some way so
check the description if you want to
read more about that but that is
currently all the info we have on him so
far
it's not complete proof it's more just a
bunch of theories with heavy evidence
all we need is for cd projekt red to
show us if we're right in the future dlc
and we'll have our answer if you enjoyed
the video let me know by leaving the
like and subscribing to the channel for
more lore content like this for
cyberpunk and other games in the future
this is easily one of cyberpunk's
biggest mysteries and one that i hope is
solved in the near future
regardless take care everyone let me
know your thoughts and goodbye
[Music]
you